I hate stand up
comedy I hate it but I've committed my
life to
it just been going around doing
this
sad you ever work a job too
[Music]
long that's what this is I've pigeon
hold myself into a dying art
form I was in Nashville and a man named
belly button opened for
me so that's where my career is
at got belly button opening up I asked
belly button too like I asked him I said
belly
button I asked him I asked him I asked
belly button I was like belly button
what are you do when you fill out a w
knot and he said what is
that so like just these are the kind of
people I associate myself with it's just
divorced men who are committing tax
fraud those are my
peers those are my peers so all things
considered you know is pretty
bad it's pretty
bad you want people to say that they be
like oh all things considered that's
that's pretty good that's really
good it's like well I feel like you're
not considering all
things like sure you're considering some
things but you're considering all things
You' be crying right
now you got to consider more things like
NPR you
know you're
inconsiderate and sometimes I'm like
having a good day I'll be having a good
day and then I remember that the oceans
are
dying did you ever get that just happy
and then you're like oh no not the
Pacific not not my favorite
ocean you ever just get ahead and you're
like a I can't right
now how could I get sucked off at a time
like
this when the whales are in their
situation there and I I couldn't
possibly succumb to some top right now
what kind of person could experience
fellatio Amit such a profound ecological
event you
know could possibly get sucked off right
now we figure out the whales then we can
get back to
me we figure out the whales we can get
back to getting sucked off but but it's
up to
us it's up to us to get back to
me it's up to us that's what they say
I'll be like it's up to us to save the
environment I'm like oh that just means
poor people with limited resour
resources and poor people don't
recycle I'm poor I don't
recycle I'm not I just put everything in
one bag and I hope for the
best that's what I fill those bags
with
hope that's why garbage bag commercials
are like look how durable this is I'm
like I know I'm not taking two trips
like I'm too
tired from being I'm
poor so
tired but it's nobody's fault you know
that the World's End
in just there's just too many
people there's too there's way too many
people wait way too that I know there's
too many people because a a child's
leash touched my
leg that that should never happen I have
have a list of things that should happen
that's not on
there I felt a tug like at my leg I was
at a corner I felt a tug like I was
being tug and I looked down I was like
oh it's probably going to be a small
dog could be a cute dog it was a small
boy and and he
wrapped he wrapped he raced around and
then his mom she went heal she healed it
he flew
back she healed a human a human was
healed and I was like whose fault is
that I didn't know who fault that I was
like is that the parent or the
kid but then I was like well we could
kill that
kid we could
kill we could kill no kid that's ever
been leashed has gone on to do great
things you know name a successful person
they've never been leashed
I guarantee it Bill Gates he seems like
he would have been but
no Greta thunberg definitely not she
sailed across the
Atlantic they don't have leashes that
long they don't long as leash going to
run you like 18 ft
retractable she would have got offshore
bounce right
back she would not have completed her
journey and I try to stay like I really
do but it's hard because other people
exist and there's like so many not you
guys not you but
them and then when you see them you'll
be like
you like I watch a man blow his nose
into his
hand if you're like oh it was in his it
was just more
hand what was in his hand more hand and
then he flung it in one
motion
I was like oh he's done this
before yeah he's done that before I'm
seeing this person's habits in real
time there's way too many people I
shouldn't see your habits you know I
should have to know you deeply and
intimately and then weigh the pros and
cons of that habit and then ultimately
choose I don't want you in my
life I shouldn't have habits forced on
me the worst habit now is everybody has
to know
everything that's my least favorite
thing everybody's got to know everything
everybody has too much information and
then once you have information you
become
insufferable just insufferable like if
you had somebody just know something at
you in these past couple years you just
have to sit there and take things being
known at you just know it just
Relentless knowing at you you're like
shut the up I already know
what I need to
know I don't need more some other scary
thing to worry
about I want to live in
ignorance but everybody knows everything
I think that just makes it a hard time
to
exist you know and I already think it's
like the hardest time to exist like I
think my generation I think we have it
the
hardest yeah
oh yeah it's so
hard man my my life so
hard Amazon Prime Apple
TV I got too many
subscriptions I didn't mean to subscribe
to such a hard
life you know and we're like the first
generation of
Roommates that's
hard it's hard that's hard hard to go
through your day-to-day knowing you're
going to go home to a grown
man you're going to go home to a grown
man just clipping his
toenails on your couch that's your couch
he didn't even split it with
you and he's on there clipping toenails
and bed shorts which are just shorts
that he wears to
bed but it's 5:00
p.m. it's 5:00 p.m. bro like did you
just wake up or are you calling it in
early
you also why do I have memorized what
you wear to
bed I don't love
you I don't care about
you you're only here cuz I need
[Laughter]
half but there's just too many people
we're running out of space like so
everybody get roommate like I have a
friend in Indiana that's a place where
you're like oh I bet but you but you own
a
house you live in Indiana why would you
live in
Indiana if you didn't have
property it's like oh he just lives in a
house with three other people so
everybody's doing very
badly cross the board everybody's doing
bad you could like see that we've been
running out of space like if you look at
technology like audio specifically for
this
joke I don't have another
example I just came up with the audio
one and I was like all right that seems
good
enough like in the early 2000s audio
everything was like surround sound you
got get a surround sound system this
Dolby Digital 500 everybody's like whoa
500 was it always 500 they're like we
don't know know but it's
loud like bring your boys over your boys
are like wow this is loud this louder
than your wife you know and it was the
early 2000s so we hated the wife you
know I don't know why I
wasn't everything was surround sound and
now audio is just noise
cancellation they're like you don't want
to hear what's going on out there
it's messed up and the walls are
thin and and you don't really have space
for four speakers and a
subwoofer the only space you can afford
is in your inner
Canal just an itty little bit of space
that's all you got
baby but my my proposal my prop my
proposition my idea to save
space is we just combin buying golf
courses and
[Laughter]
cemeteries that's a good idea be
serious got be serious about
this I think that makes the game a lot
more fun you know you got to pitch it
over a
crypt like yeah I earned that part four
I had to go over George
III I also think of makes it a lot more
convenient I'll be convenient you know
cuz a lot of people playing
golf hey they're also on the back nine
of life
so like oh yeah Grandpa dropped dead
right in the sand trap we stepped over
him and then we hit the country club for
a
BLT but we just don't have like a
release anymore like there's no release
anymore cuz we don't have kids so
there's no
release it's weird to have a kid
now it's that's weird to
me is that weird to you like I see a
pregnant lady I'm like that's weirdo
Behavior you're weirdo you're weird to
me you don't have
foresight we're running out of water
you're going to have a thing that needs
water like
that it's selfish I think to take our
water I personally I'm going to start
drinking 18 cups a day I don't want any
water
left for your dumbass kid that's why I
respect the guy who walks around with
The
Jug he's got that strong jug arm I'm
like yeah get that water out of
here I don't want to see any more water
around
here like I think that people that have
kids now like it's just for
Instagram it's it's just for somebody
who could never get 100 likes before and
they're like oh maybe with this
baby I could get the kind of page
activity I always
wanted people didn't like me for me
maybe they like me for me and my
baby dress my baby up like a bear you
know do a photo shoot in the woods for
some
reason look back at the baby real scared
oh my
God my baby's a good
actor 120 one likes worth it worth it
worth the greatest pain of my
life we don't have kids so there's no
release because the release used to be
like if you're having a bad day you know
like feeling bad like you're feeling bad
about yourself you know you you would go
home and and you would hit your kid you
hit your kid beat your kid up
you're like yes I did something with my
life I struck my child
you know but I can't go home and hit
Evan he's a grown
man he does CrossFit that's a
untrustworthy exercise I don't even know
if they know what they're doing in there
they're throwing anything around that's
too random I can't predict
random he stays in his room for too long
at a time I don't know what's going on
in
there just push-ups and
planning I assume
you come out every once in a while shows
me a YouTube
video I fake
laugh I love everything Jordan B
Peterson has to
say no and I have to say that you know I
have to say that because I don't want to
be a part of his cycle of
violence I I pay too much rent to be a
part of somebody's cycle of
violence that's not included in the
utilities
that's why I think
everybody's medicated now you know like
we all have anxiety and
depression because the cure for anxiety
and
depression was child
abuse maybe I wouldn't need to be on
clopin if I could just hit a
kid
get off this Lexapro I could just
kick so I think it's a hard time to
exist I do feel
like I still have
potential
yeah yeah I got
28 I feel like I still have
potential that's why I think it's a good
time to kill
[Laughter]
myself you got to do
it way too long you don't have potential
anymore timing is
everything don't do it you can still
have a
kid
just holding for the
[Applause]
edit I'm not up here dealing with
hecklers
tonight usually man I would cut
you
up but there there are there are cameras
here
yeah I'm 28 I feel like I still have
potential that's why I think it's a good
time to kill
[Laughter]
myself cuz you got to do it while you
still
have you wait too long you don't have it
anymore 28 you kill yourself people are
like
no he had big things
coming
potentially then you're 39 you kill
yourself people like he's a good
guy 39 years that's a good enough time
to get stuff
[Music]
done and I know suicide is like a taboo
topic I
know it's
Taboo it's taboo they're like don't talk
about it
dustoo well that's just because people
are still Christians you
know cuz they can't
read and like Christian ideologies are
so built into our society that we think
that like life is a gift from God so if
you take your own life you're slapping
God in the
face because life is a
gift from
God but if Life's a gift from God this
God sucks at giveing gift
suck gave the same to everybody why
that's how I know God is not a
woman that's a thoughtless Gift Giver
that's a male
trait this seems pretty last minute did
you stop at a
kiosk why don't you take a hint next
time I don't think any of us wanted to
be
here I don't get get a gift receipt or
anything they're like you could have
store credit hard pass store credit
never works
out I'm glad we can like joke about
mental health stuff now we can joke
about
that people used to just get
mad talk about anything mental health
people would get mad you'd be like I'm
sad they'd be like well that makes me
angry with you
okay I feel like we're all experiencing
emotions I wish you had
range but people just they didn't know
what to do they don't know how to deal
with it they used to just get
mad like when I was
13 um I got suspended from school cuz my
my school found out that I was cutting
myself and then they got mad at
me everybody got mad at me they got mad
they sent me home they didn't know what
to do so they sent me home and I was
like
okay I'll go home to where all the
knives
are you should have thought that through
tools of my
trade I'm cutting my wrist up breaking
new ground for the
next generation of emo kids you
know they're going to have
therapy and they do now I'm a
hero
but sometimes I do want a GI
receipt you know sometimes I do people
be like why why do you want to return
this I'll be like well look who's doing
well this a selfish
thought look who's doing like
billionaires that's who's doing
well have you heard about
this you heard about have you seen these
people they got a billion dollars
s made
up billion dollars have you seen these
people they they are so
ugly I'm like how do you have so much
but also so
little and they won't die that's my
problem with billionaires they won't
die you never hear about a billionaire
dying the only time you hear about a
billionaire is when they got more
money I thought they were going to start
dropping then we could all get a little
bonus you know spread the
wealth I don't know how the economy
works but they won't die I was trying to
correlate you know I was trying to make
correlations trying to figure out why
they won't die you ever correlate
correlate I doing my own
research trying to figure out a vaccine
to get rid of
billionaires they won't die and then I
was like whoa do you think the secret to
eternal life is having sex with
children because that's what every
documentary was about for like four
months I was like oh I'm on to
something guess the Fountain of Youth is
the
youth
I didn't like it I wasn't like
Stokes I wasn't like oh cool this is
happening that's
great I didn't want that
information I was like why are we
documenting this we should help these
kids and they're like no we need
content yeah we need some content
content's actually more important than
human
life
what do you think comes
first the billion
dollars or the
[Laughter]
pedophilia I think it's a billion
dollars that's why I question anybody
who's
ambitious oh you wake up early okay you
have ulterior mod
I don't trust that I don't trust that
schedule Mark Wahlberg's
on why do we know he wakes up every day
at 3:25 a.m. we got to look into
that but I don't have a fix for that you
know I don't have a solve I don't know
how to get rid of them but how do we
know that human sacrifice doesn't
work we don't I don't I've never had a
good heart
[Laughter]
Harvest 20 years I haven't had one good
harvest
I my crops aren't doing anything I I
can't even keep a succulent
alive need to sacrifice somebody to keep
my desert flowers
awake and that's a hard joke for me to
get through
usually it is is cuz I have bad
energy I have bad
energy I know that about myself I have
bad multiple times people have been like
to me Oh I thought you hated me when we
met I did I still
do got transparent bad
energy you know I'm
toxic I'm toxic but I'm not masculine
[Laughter]
I'm just
regular I'm just regular
toxic my toxicity has no
masculinity not
masculine this guy came up to me at a
barbecue he didn't even introduce
himself you know no handshake no no he
just said to me he said uh you look like
you take baths
no hand no just you
bathe I wanted to be so mad like no I
shower take hot
showers this is new
skin my showers are so hot I just shed
in
there oh I wanted to be mad like that
but then I remembered like I love a
bath
o God damn a candle my laptop on the
toilet like a little TV stand like some
Epona like I'll shrivel up I watch a
whole show
I I'll watch all of the crown I love I
love the I love a drama I love the
queen but he was like an older comic so
he was like trying to make a joke like
insinuate that I'm soft you know that's
what he's doing he's like you got a weak
Spirit that's that's what I took from
that you're soft and yeah I'm soft I'm
soft cuz after I get out of the
tub I I got a good skincare regiment I I
got moisturizers and oils they they trap
the moisture
and and I only tell you that to say that
I have good
skin that's how you know I'm a good
person
you know I got good SK I'm toxic but I'm
a good person because I have good
skin good people have good
skin good people have great
skin somebody with a great skin you're
like you did charity work
here evil people awful
skin that's who a three in-one shampoo
conditioner body wash is
for just for like an evil guy so he can
like shower quick and then get back to
harassing
people you know that's how I know the
Insurrection smelled like Old
[Laughter]
Spice yeah Old Spice the scent of
rebellion but yeah I'm a good
[Laughter]
person
I'm still not
happy I want to be
happy maybe I just need
money not a billion dollar but
some how much money would you like a
little more than what I
have like I want they say the Baseline
for happiness is you got to make like
$85,000 a year and then after that it
doesn't matter but the Baseline
85 anything after it doesn't matter
that's what you need for Peak
happiness and I just feel like I would
be a lot happier if I didn't know
that I want have to know that is that
before or after tax because either way
it seems
unachievable cuz I want money like I
want to be a republican so
bad but I'm fiscally liberal right now
I care about stuff because my fiscal
situation fiscally I care but I want to
be a
republican like the evil kind not the
kind where you're like I just ignore
him I'm be an evil evil kind I want to
like wake up in the morning drink stem
cells you know I'm pro-life but I got a
wine seller of stem
cells I want to be a hypocrite I want
hypocrite
money I want to say that I'm all lives
matter but really I just mean
me that's the kind of Republican I want
to
be but I'm fiscally
[Music]
liberal but I always am like fighting
off being Republican you know
like it's just an inner battle I have to
deal with every day which side am I on
there's only
two
like I do think that everybody deserves
to make like a decent living
wage yeah but I do think the people
making $15 an hour now are getting
really
cocky they need to be
humbl because I paid with a $10 bill at
a Popeyes and the cashier he held it up
to the
light he unfurled it into the light I
was like why would you do this in front
of everybody like we're bracket
buddies we're bracket buddy we're in the
same bracket like you going to turn your
back on your bracket buddy like you
think I'm fleecing the Popeyes with fake
tens the change is 89 cents like what
kind of long game do you think I'm
playing to embarrass me like
that now I'm going to make so much money
I'm going to come back and I'm going to
buy this
franchise and fire you in a dramatic
fashion teach you you never turn your
back on your bracka buddy
again but I do still think people
decently everybody deserve that cuz
liberal but I'm okay with women making
[Laughter]
less no just cuz they haven't been
working this long you
got you got to put your time in you know
you don't have the seniority
honey and I'm sure some suffer Jets were
like whoa chill a minute like can we
just do
parttime I still want to stay at home
vacuum andt take
[Laughter]
valium nothing chills me out like a hum
of a
Hoover I'm off the
[Laughter]
valley I've I've never never have money
though like I've never had a
refrigerator that didn't sound like it
wasn't struggling to
breathe you know every fridge I've ever
had just has a knife wound in
it and everything sweats
immediately most of my life I could tell
something tasted like
fridge I'm like oh this got a hint of
kitchen a on it you know best before you
put it
in my friend was like well what are you
doing to say what are you doing to say
are you
investing
no no I'm not doing that I'm just
waiting I'm just wait because I heard
somebody say once that they came into
some
money
so that's kind of what I'm hoping is the
case for
me but it's okay I'm just I'm just not
important it's man I'm not important
like I'm not important enough to walk up
an
escalator you know like I stay to the
right like I don't have to be anywhere
on time I see people like run up and
escalator I'm like oh that's a role
model that's a role model he's late for
a hangout on Google right now he's
having Google Hangouts I I never hung
out on
Google I don't hang out there I just
[Music]
Zoom but money's always going to be a
problem under capitalism you
know I got too
much yeah I got too much information I
know about
capitalism somebody knew stuff at me
once and I was like oh I regurgitate
[Laughter]
that you know I I live in the biggest
capitalist of them all I live in
America I hate
it I hate America CU I don't drink
milk you like the only people that like
love America they like love
Dairy they love Dairy you'd be like uh
can I get oat milk they're like oh
you're a domestic
terrorist we don't agree with your dairy
alternative
choices
because I was at a diner I saw old guy
drinking like a tall tall glass of
milk and I was like oh that's a
patriot that's what a patriot looks like
they they love milk they can't connect
with their
daughter they got sleep apony at
that's that's what America is to
me I support the troops though
yeah I
support I support the troops I just
don't support the surprise Welcome Home
Videos so welcome home videos I don't
like
that bother me like you're going over
there being all extra over
there being all extra to come home and
go viral with a video
why don't you just learn editing skills
man going over there bombing
hospitals she can come back and make a
video seems disingenuous to
me like wow son you're so big now last
time I saw you I hadn't even bombed a
hospital
yet so good to see you dude you grew up
quick I bomb like three hospitals
the ones that bother me the most are the
ones with the
dogs where they like oh look how happy
look how happy my dog is to see me after
all this time can you believe how happy
my dog
is it's like are you
sure are you sure about
that because I've met some dogs and they
were new to
[Laughter]
me and let me tell you they were pretty
excited you think this dog thinks that I
went to war that that's stupid that's a
stupid you got a dumb dog I will never
step foot on a battlefield for a flag
you got a dumb dog you better hope I
don't get drafted
too I'm going to give away my platoon's
position with a vape
pen I'm going to get sniped in the head
cuz I'm addicted to
vape they're going to be on the was like
so what was the downfall for your Modern
Warfare well we were addicted to
jeweling and the little lights gave us
away it was the little lights that did
us we tried to flank but the
lights it was a
massacre and I'm from Canada like I I
don't even know we have an
army I know we have a Navy but what's
that besides making soup on a
boat which might be the most dangerous
one you know depending on how rocky them
waves are and how hot that soup
is yeah I was in the Navy you can tell
by these third degree burns
huh the clam chowder almost got
me the Pea Soup took my brother in
[Music]
arms I do like being Canadian in America
that's cool it's just like being in a
really easy escape
room if you don't know what an escape
room is that's when you have so much
privilege you pay somebody to take it
away
like oh AB I have loads of privilege I
don't have to do
this I hate this team building
exercise but whenever
somebody in America finds out from
Canada which is you tell
them no he's guessing
that everybody always says the same
thing they always say the same thing to
you they're always like oh so if you're
free
healthare oh your Healthcare is free
you're free healthare they just say free
healthcare it's like yeah I guess that's
not really what I was doing up
there I wasn't pushing that through
Parliament
like me and the Prime Minister wning
Cahoots on that one bud
but it's free it's cheap I don't know it
it's a better
system so it's not
funny you know you have to explain it's
not
funny like healthcare is funny in
America cuz everybody's like oh it's
bad and then they're like yeah it's bad
and then that's the end of the
conversation that's what I think is
funny blatantly ignoring a
flaw like Healthcare in America is so
bad that's where the make aish
Foundation was founded
that's
funny that's
funny they're like good news bad
news
so your son is going to die but we could
get him a FaceTime with Anne
hathway yeah we got an hathway on the
line she's going to sing some lay Miz
for
Jaden hopefully that eases the pain of
his stage four
mesothelioma yeah Jaden's got the
mesothelioma bad at stage
4 only the musings of an Hathaway can
help him
now are bad we didn't really consider
many
[Music]
so we don't have a system in
place I don't know about you guys though
but I feel like cancer should chill out
should chill you know take it
easy like just like especially with the
big
words like the big like just be cancer
we don't have a cure for you yet why you
got to flex on
us with these big words just be yourself
big
guy take it easy you're killing us out
there
pancreatic
saroma chill
out take it give me my grandparents
back give
them give them
back no I lost my grandparents young
everybody else lost their grandparents
last
year
[Applause]
oh you didn't know about
mortality okay I'm
[Laughter]
toxic I do think about cancer all the
time
you know like every
day every day I'm thinking about it you
know because it could be in you right
now
dormant just in there
dormant just in the
shadows like you're in my
prostate get out of I just got into
that now you're in there there's
definitely not room for the both of us
yet
why can come back later when there's
some more
room I'll forget my keys at home I'll be
like halfway down a
block oh oh no that's the
cancer they creeping up on me and now
I'm
forgetful that's got to be a
[Music]
symptom you ever trip like walking
upstairs and you're like oh God I have a
tumor I have a tumor and it's malignant
I wish it was benign but it's
malignant and I can't afford to see a
doctor and I'm too old to see
an this system doesn't work for
me
I just don't want to get old scares me
getting old is
Scary like I don't want to get old
because I don't want
hindsight that seems like a
curse like to look back on your life
with perfect clarity and be like oh yeah
I could have done things better
easily oh oh man I made all the wrong
choices wait wait you're telling me all
I had to do was tell the
truth oh who
knew who knew life would have been
easier if I wasn't a pathological
liar you ever lie so hard you have to
learn
Cantonese I was on dualingo for like six
weeks like why did I tell people I was
bilingual
I don't know how I'm get at
old I don't want to do like classic
white
you know I don't want to do classic
white just like repress my feelings
in a reclining
chair you know you know the kind of
chair where it's like it's got the baked
handle and it doesn't work the first
time and then the second time they pull
it they got
whiplash
I'm I'm trying you know I'm trying to be
like
healthy like
uh trying
to open
up trying to open up be in a healthy
relationship be opened
up like I'm in coup's counseling right
now so
that's that's
good yeah that's good couple counseling
that's good
it's good it's good to be doing
it it's
bad how we got
there but it is good to be doing it I
love it but sometimes I just wish that
everybody I ever had sex with just died
[Laughter]
after like it's just easier to be in
morning than it is to be open and
vulnerable
with you and that joke is a defense
[Laughter]
mechanism I was trying to take
responsibility for my actions you know
we don't really do that
anymore we don't like everybody's in
therapy now but nobody takes
responsibility everybody's just like oh
yeah my
bad I'm working on it
so it's just my
demons
my bad I just got demons
so it's not my fault I got demons I'm
sorry I cheated I have
demons you don't have demons you are a
demon you need to R strategize people
trusted
you and that's not anti-cheating
sentiment I think cheating is good
makes your work
harder you don't do things you normally
wouldn't do ask things you normally like
how was your
day cheating is good until you
[Laughter]
come then you're just left with
regret just just sit in on the edge of a
bed understanding what R&B really
is like wow I didn't know R&B was in the
cards for
me I didn't know I would ever relate to
this WOW rhythm and
blues I understand both
now and I've
cheated and I've been cheated on but I
still don't think that's the biggest
betrayal in
life I think the biggest betrayal in
life is that the Q-tip is not actually
for the
ear you're like but it fits perfectly
they're like don't put it in
there like I'm going to do it
anyway I get these demons
out need to put my speakers back
in
I've been trying to get rid of my
[Music]
demons like I got sober like I've been
sober for a while
um I hate
it I I hate being
sober because you just remember
everything no vices just your life up
until now just
remembering everything and that's the
only thing that's worse than
forgetting is
remembering just remember you're like oh
my God why is that still in
there I thought I would have
disassociated by
now like I remembered that I got into a
revolving door with another
man just sharing a great just split in a
quarter and I just said I'm here
[Laughter]
too and he turned and looked at me like
I we're in a confine space right
now why would you do this to
us so I don't know what I need but I
need to forget that
I I don't know I need a pill addiction
or something
I do know that I don't want to be with
like another person
again like I'm
good I just don't I don't like being
with somebody for the first time that's
why and I love my
relationship
I just hate the first time with somebody
else you know cuz you don't know each
other so you're like always feeling each
other
out and so something always
happens something always happens I was
with this girl once we're in her room
and she grabbed something off her bed
and she held it up and she said uh this
is my
blankie
she held it up she was like this my
blankie this my blankie from when I was
a
kid she held it up like that like MC
Beth and I was sober so that's just in
here forever
like if I was drunk I be I don't give a
f I'll wipe myself off with it
like why do you have a blankie Miss put
the blankie away put it in a box and
then put it in the nook above the closet
where memories are supposed to go push
those memories under the bed I don't
want to know you like
that like I can't be with somebody like
that
like I can't like somebody that's got
keepsakes from their
childhood you know like they had a good
childhood that's that's not my type like
I need somebody with
trauma you know keep it exciting with
the
trauma that's why I think I exclusively
date older
women you know because they've been
around longer and they're a woman so
it's more likely that something horrible
has happened to
[Laughter]
them and they have more flavor like a
cast
iron
[Applause]
yeah I'm like uh don't use soap I want
to taste your
upbringing I want to taste weekends at
davs yes soap ruins
it yeah I got to cast iron during the
pandemic
and then I applied my new knowledge of
it to the only other thing I
know
[Laughter]
jokes one of the only things I
known I do feel like the only thing I
need to be happy is like no
awareness that's what I need I need no
awareness that's what I need to be happy
happy like you guys are probably all
pretty aware
right yeah and that's why you're
unhappy you but you take that you take
that awareness away like life is easy
you know you just love
Disney you know like you got frames with
quotes in
them that's what I want I want the
simple life I want to frame some
quotes I want to get my art from
Ikea like I want know
awareness none of it like I want to get
into a pyramid scheme
early you know just be at the ground
just Build It Up be at the top of the
triangle just rope in my family and
acquaintances and then just reap the
benefits of their financial
ruin and then at the end of the day I
call myself an
entrepreneur that's the lack of
awareness I want I want entrepreneur in
my
bio with a code next to it for
20% off a product nobody's clicking
on I want no awareness I want no spatial
awareness I want to stand this close to
you in a lineup and
just just just breathe on your neck and
feel
nothing you're mad for a week somebody
breathe on me well I got no awareness
I'm breathing on
everybody I don't care I got no
awareness
I want to go back through a revolving
door with somebody and not
care I want no awareness like I want to
be a
lingerer I want to linger you know I
want to linger I want to be a lingerer
linger around float through life just H
just
lingering like I want to say goodbye to
you at a party and then you see me 10
minutes later
you're like I thought you were
leaving I don't really know what I'm
doing I just exist to be you know I
simply
am I want no I'm a lingerer I want no
awareness I want to trust
companies that's the lack of awareness I
want I'll be like oh these companies are
they're looking out for me
I'm the little
guy like I want to retweet my
bank like I genuinely want to give my
bank a retweet like oh what you guys are
doing on social media over at the bank
man I love it you're killing
it all that gay during pride month
I trust that that's cool
that's doesn't seem advantageous of
movements at all I love that my bank is
into social change thank you for the
premiums I love I want to love the bank
online banking no inline banking I want
to be at the bank I love it
there I I want to love the bank oh man
they're putting necklaces on the pens of
the bank I love
it I love the bank the pens got beads on
them I want to be like that but I'm not
like I don't
trust I don't trust companies I don't
trust corporate I don't trust the
government like that's why I never use
the same signature
twice I know I don't want to give them
anything
consistent catch me in belly button if
you
[Laughter]
can I don't even trust the Girl Scouts
anymore I don't trust the Girl
Scouts they lost me
Girl Scouts of the Girl Scouts cookie
I'm done with
them I don't trust
that because uh when Amy Coney Barrett
was nominated to the Supreme Court she's
a right-wing Justice she's
pro-life the Girl Scouts they
congratulated
her they congratulated her publicly they
were like yes
Queen break the glass ceiling that's
what they said publicly
which I've always felt like that's a
weird architectural
design like the glass
ceiling like is a
ceiling it's not even the
roof so you're just breaking through to
like another level of misogyny
that that seems like a bad but that's
women's Planet I don't speak for women
I don't speak for women you guys keep
doing the damn thing I'm I'm so proud of
[Laughter]
you you're killing it right
now but Girl Scouts they congratulated
Amy Coney Barrett I was like wow that's
crazy like Girl Scouts doesn't believe
in a woman's right to
choose like that's what I thought their
whole thing
was I thought they're out here scouting
choices
but apparently
not apparently not then I sat on it for
a while you know cuz I was so mad I was
so pissed at the girl
scous they let me down man I was so
mad and then it started to make sense I
was like it makes sense that they would
congratulate her you know because if we
keep having these abortions
like who is going to sell these
cookies like who is going to do it cuz
I'm not going to buy a cookie for some
old
lady like I'll date her I won't buy a
cookie from her
like you know so I understand Girl
Scouts Nuance
take on abortion you know we we are
killing their
employees
cookie sales is a Fickle
business there're going to be a lot more
Girl Scouts in
Texas I don't make the laws I just have
the
information I don't want to have
it that's why I feel so bad all the
time also I feel like I've been
depressed just because nobody's told me
a secret in a
while you know I just need a good secret
to keep me
going just need a good
secret like is anybody ever told you
something you're like oh I'm going live
forever I'm live
forever you're a demon but I'm going to
live
forever like I need something evil you
know like something that could ruin a
family that's the kind of secret I
need something that could up a
will that's what I need to keep my heart
pumping but no
matter how bad my mental health gets
like it'll always be better than
somebody that drives a truck
[Laughter]
like a Ford
F-150 I just feel like those are the
least introspective people on the
planet least introspective people on the
because every time they get out of the
truck every time they get out of the
truck they tuck the mirror
in they tuck it in it's like why not
instead of tucking in why don't you take
a good long hard look in
it
and reflect you
know maybe you're the reason your family
doesn't talk to
you you know it's not gas pric of the
government like it's just who you are
it's a human being because people that
drive trucks they're always like they're
always so mad about the gas you
know they're always so mad about the gas
but it's like well you drive the largest
recreational vehicle
available if you just knew who you were
and drove a Chevy Vault you wouldn't
have that problem
know people would still come home for
Thanksgiving and if you didn't need all
that gas then they never would have
taken down the
towers
what you got consider all
things thank
you
nobody asked for the but I made it
anyway cuz I'm really bold okay haven't
cleaned my house in weeks looking like a
hurricane went through hey baby I'm
trying to see some cheeks and SL on my
girls twin PE nobody asked for that
anyway but I had to say it cuz it's my
song so you got to take nobody asked for
the but I made it anyway cuz I'm
really B okay have clean my house in
weeks looking like a hurricane went
through it hey baby and nobody asked
about your kids and nobody care put this
white baby pictures away and nobody
about your scpt remind me of every
that live in LA and nobody want to work
when ndy making millions PS and
NS like L keep talking about nfts
like I know what the that is but I
don't so don't try to educate me on some
I don't even I want you can
Min these nuts putting them on the
blockchain for half a
[Music]
million
all